aber so nur salat ist für mich so ein
bisschen zu sehr schmeckt so sei nach
bald herbei ja sagt man so anstößig
kanal audio und glocken und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen bio
ich hoffe natürlich geht es gut wir
haben heute freitag das kommt mir jetzt
immer hier in montag mittwoch und
freitags die haupt videos letzten montag
haben wir bereits beim schlechtesten
deutschen restaurant auf lieferanten
bestellt und ich habe ja gesagt du
kannst dich erst mal wissen
ich habe ja in dem video schon gesagt
das ist jetzt öfter gern mal wieder so
was gehen wird wie schlecht ist das
restaurant hier prima beute machen
direkt mal weiter und zwar hab ich was
rausgesucht ich würde sagen das könnte
man unter italienisch fassen das
restaurant ist zwar angegeben mit
mexikanisch deutsch und italienisch hat
aber eigentlich nur italienische
produkte zu verkaufen ein bisschen wird
ich würde sagen wir lagen leichter ich
zeig euch das direkt mal und bin ich mal
gespannt was häufig hier so auf diesem
wunderschönen luxus sterne tisch landet
ist es das schlechteste oder das ist das
schlechteste zweieinhalb sterne auf die
brandung da ist schon sehr sehr schlecht
auch so weitermachen
wir bestellen heute bei folgenden saison
es kann sein also wenn ich das schlecht
bewertet dann sehe ich das alles weil
ich will ja keinen schaden so dass dinge
nennt sich wir schauen uns hier ganz
kurz mal denke das ist halt die adressen
wie bei lieferanten brünn steht bei
google steht ihr das ist ein e commerce
dienst in köln auf jeden fall weiß ich
aber dass sich bei der richtigen adresse
denn wer in den rezensionen auch keinen
fall bestellen haben über zwei stunden
gebrauch anstatt sich zu entschuldigen
waren die dann auch patzig ich würde von
einer bestellung abraten habe eine
verbrannte calzone versalzene lasagne
und eine nicht scharfe pizza diabolo
bekommen ehec bestellung kommen komplett
falsch und kalt an auf nachfrage wird
man unmöglich
beleidigen abgewiesen also das sind die
drei google rezension sehr sehr schlecht
natürlich sehr schade
dann zeige ich euch hier und auch die
lieferantenbewertung ich haben wir
eigentlich ein paar die ganz gut sind
dann hier ist die negativen essen war
alles was ich besonders pizza ich habe
noch nie so eine schlechte pizza
gegessen ich sollte nicht bestellen gute
deutsch selten so schlechtes essen
geliefert bekommen los calamares á la
romana er andreas kohli an hat auf
spanisch oder rezensionen geschrieben
das macht natürlich auch sehr viel sinn
der hat wahrscheinlich direkt von köln
nach barcelona gestellt leider war das
essen nicht mehr heiß und die pommes
waren schwammig pommes gomez also ja gut
das gibt auch deutsches essen aber
wirklich also die 90 prozent der karte
ist italienisch deswegen steht bei dem
titel vom video wahrscheinlich mit all
ihren aufnahmen über zwei stunden ist
doch kein essen geliefert worden
dabei erscheint die bestellungen bei
lieferando ausgeliefert das restaurant
geht nicht ans telefon
grausam sehr schlecht ihr solltet euch
überlegen was ihr da verkauft 30 euro in
den wind geschmissen von pizza zu den
auflaufenden messe ich schlecht junge
einem lieferanten aneinander waffen oder
also rechtschreibung ist da nicht von
jedem die große stärke aber ich schreibe
natürlich nach jedem video nach jedem
essen was ich geleistet habe meine
eigene rezeption und bleibt ihr euch
dann immer ein okay wir haben auf jeden
fall jetzt genug gelagert und bestellen
mal
wir schauen uns mal gespeichert haben
ich würde sagen wir nehmen von allem
etwas grüner salat weil einfach mal rein
das ist gut so einfach sonst an soll
dann machen wir weiter ich habe dort
schon mit jure gesprochen ich kann also
ich will natürlich mal möglich hier
bestellen schaffe das nicht mehr alles
selber manchmal schmeckt auch einfach
nicht dann kann man es auch nicht essen
aber pizza salami ist diesmal für dich
deswegen nehmen wir auch die pizza
saarland mit kleine variante wir
scrollen weiter runter und kommen dann
jetzt zu spaghetti da würde ich dann
einfach mal sagen und woher weiß ich
will nicht schneit es irgendwie lame das
ist so das kann man ja eigentlich nicht
finde ich nicht so bolognese handvoll
viele schon echte dabei ist die wir hier
tortellini mit tortellini nach rooneys
mag ich eigentlich klingt lecker tun wir
auch rein und dann habe ich eben schon
gesehen
die bieten auch an für 11 eur 50 oder so
ich hab ich feiere so seit einem jahr so
tintenfischringe echt ab alter also im
urlaub in spanien wenn ich mal
meine eltern da urlaub machen oder so
immer schön im restaurant gibt es jetzt
immer kann aber das ist auch in italien
gibt es das wahrscheinlich auch an der
küste über eine kann man jetzt nicht
verallgemeinern
deswegen sage ich auch mal hier ich weiß
nicht ob das typisch italienisches essen
ist aber das nehmen wir auch mal mit mal
gucken ob wir das können mit pommes
frites ist dazu tomaten sahnesoße und
pepe uhr ist also das wird sich sehr
sehr lecker an
da hoffe ich mal dass mich das überzeugt
wobei die bewertung halter was anderes
sagen wir haben jetzt 26 eurem wagen
habe ich würde sagen ich bestelle das
mal und dann sehen wir uns auch die
liefern liefert seit einer stunde das
habe ich jetzt bestelle ich eine stunde
müssen erwarten also wie man es gerade
16 35 17 uhr 35 sollte das essen
spätestens da sein was man auch wirklich
so lange dauert oder ein bisschen kürzer
wir sehen uns recht wieder ich habe bock
und ich habe vor allem der hunger und
ich hoffe ihr auch also gut euch bringt
es nichts aber bist du ja heute das
essen ist schon da altersgerechter ich
gedacht ich muss kurz mal den kopfhörern
boxen also wenig ist es nicht muss man
ja mal der salat also der hat nur 250
gekostet das ist schon gut mit soße noch
dazu aber ich habe doch eigentlich
joghurtdressing ausgewählt oder standard
ich weiß keine mainz werden egal witze
brötchen haben wir doch umsonst und
draußen auch nicht schlecht ich muss mal
ganz kurzen noch was erzählen abbas und
noch mehr vor
also danke man sich nicht merken wir
noch keine salami pizza erster eindruck
ist nicht schlecht nur eine kurze rede
ich euch noch erzählen wollte und zwar
habe ich eben einen anruf bekommen von
denen die meinen ceo lieferando gibt und
seit zwei monaten das geld nicht weiter
du musst bar bezahlt und nicht an so hey
ich kann jetzt nicht wieder
das ist ja dann doppelt bezahlt meint
die nanny wir melden denen das dass die
das studieren und dann zahlst du mich
sagt nee nee das mach ich den schönsten
wenn wir nachher haben die sonst
theoretisch zwei mal das geld bekommen
weil ich kann mir auch nicht vorstellen
dass nicht voran besitzt das nicht an
sie weitergibt so das geld das geht ja
ich hatte jetzt kein bargeld jetzt habe
ich mit den vereinbart dass ich das
selber studiere und die morgen noch mal
vorbeikommen und ich das geld bar gebe
also ein bisschen wird es da schon könnt
ihr eure meinung in die kommentare
schreiben
kommen wir mal ganz locker lässt sich
mit dem salat an ich bin mal gespannt
also wie gesagt zwei haltestellen
bewertungen sieht auf den ersten
eindruck aus wie 4 3 bis 5 sterne ist
nicht wie beim döner bisschen rein
geworfen so rückt ja aber sie doch
frisch aus der salat ist überhaupt nicht
brauchen oder so da hatte ich auf jeden
fall schon schlechtere erfahrungen ich
finde es sehr frisch das ist so essig 30
glaube ich feiere ich jetzt nicht ganz
so aber ein bisschen was tue ich mal
drauf und ich möchte das soll ja noch
waren frisch und ich finde jemanden wenn
ich sollte also ich kann nicht so salat
als vorspeise ist und ich es den salat
immer zum hauptgericht dazu weißt du
dann weißt du so irgendwie in dein
hauptgericht rein und dann noch bisschen
salat dann aber so nur salat ist für
mich so ein bisschen zu sehr schmeckt
user nach bald ja sagt man so nah gut
also salat in ordnung schmeckt gut ist
jetzt nichts persönliches das hier
müssten die tortellini seien ein
impressum
ich mache dir mit dem color marius
weiter da ist ja sogar mit koketten aber
ich danke hätten angegeben oder sind die
immer mit also ich weiß nicht warum du
nicht willst du bestellte ja da machen
wir doch jetzt direkt mal die zitrone
schaut euch mal die tintenfischringe an
ich muss sagen die sind irgendwie so ein
bisschen dunkeln ja fast schon ein
bisschen matsch ich bin die mehr so
krank wie gewohnt aber hier für immer
hier rein so richtig matschig sinnlos
oder aber gut ich will nicht verurteilen
wir probieren jetzt macht vielleicht
sehr geschmack bei einer nicht noch eine
soße auch bei ja einfach so ich muss
sagen die sind wirklich sehr sehr salzig
ja es stand ja auch einmal den
kommentaren das ist alles versalzen war
wie ein bisschen nachhelfen kann ich gar
nicht echte menge sagt schon damals
strenge ordnung weil du schon besser
gegessen aber auch schon schlechtere 8
punkte von 57
weil er habe ich nicht verstand mit
folgen und theorie selbst mal
ausprobieren was brennt sondern auf
keinen fall
wir sind echt gut also kann man
auf jeden fall gut essen dann fahren wir
weiter mit dem trottoir linie napoli
passt mal auf
auch hier würde ich sagen erster
eindruck ist nicht schlecht sieht aus
wie immer
so also auch wenn ich sehr selten
tortellini bestelle aber warum sind die
auch noch ja bald mit kursexplosion
weist sich mit tortellini verbinde
wir waren auf klassenfahrt in der neuen
klasse kann fahren so in der wildnis
irgendwo im nirgendwo
wir mussten uns selber verpflegen mit
diesen gas grillen und sowas und hab
dann auch so fertigt ottelini die man
einfach nur erhitzen musste die an
welche mal gezaubert und dann haben wir
die darin gemacht und die haben einfach
so ekelhaft geschmeckt ich weiß nicht
wer wird den falschfahrer oder was ich
da falsch gemacht hat und dann haben wir
die in busch gekippt und unser lehrer
hatte soll seinen hund daheim und dieser
hund hat immer alles gefüttert was ihr
weggeschmissen haben und ihnen den rest
von der kassenhalle der und marketing
verschlimmern
und der konnte gar nichts mehr und dann
meint unsere lehrer am nächsten tag wer
hat denn diese tortellini es gegeben und
ich habe dir einfach nur in wulffs
geschüttet na ja also das ist die story
unter den tortellini diese gesprächen
aber an sich echt ganz lecker also hat
mich jetzt nicht um aber kann man essen
geht auf seinem kopf der soße fällt mir
auch zu diesem calamares doch die sind
von der kampf kommen wir mal zu was das
gut
auf den ersten blick sieht das sehr sehr
nice aus deswegen würde ich sagen ich
schneide mir da mal kurz ein stück ab
leute ich bin mir gerade schon fleißig
die pizza am garteneingang hier mit
einer bastelschere man kann auch diese
nehmen die noch so musste dabei haben
weisst du kennst du noch aus dem
kindergarten sebastian véron aber
tatsächlich da kann man sowas kann man
sich sein eigenes muster kreieren
meister das ist schon echt nice ja also
auch die pizza für mich total
ich weiß gar nicht was was also was das
die leute von becker hatten hat die
bewertung so schlecht war
er wünscht sich ja auch zum rap video
ich bin nicht so der salami pizza wenn
die haben jetzt bestellt wegen juli das
stellte fressen kann
heute muss ich dann auch die pfütze als
wirklich sehr sehr nice aber mir
schmeckt salami auf einer pizza einfach
nicht so gut
also ich muss sagen es war wirklich ein
erfolgreiches video ich finde die haben
sehr gutes essen gemacht ist kam schnell
also von mir gibt's für beide sachen 55
jahren kann ich euch jetzt noch hier
einbinden oder auch das sind dann muss
ich auch nicht viel zu schreiben essen
war toll ich habe euch ausgefallen
kommentiert sehr gerne bei welchen
restaurants oder welche richtung wir als
nächstes bestellen sondern auch
lieferant und das schlechteste
vielleicht auch mal das beste zeugnis
ablegt auf jeden fall auf meinen neuen
kanal ob alexa oder gibt es jeden tag in
action video und wir sehen uns dann am
montag wieder
vermutlich gibt es ein neues video aber
nicht den kanal